[Musique]
sommes réunis aujourd'hui dans le cas de
la restitution de l'étude filière ya que
nous réalisons dans le cas de notre
activité de développement économique est
le père paris saclay nous avons monté
pour cela la saq à l'aspect
d'accélération de transfert de
technologie qui a une très bonne
connaissance des acteurs du territoire
et une vision aussi à 300° des
différents laboratoires publics qui le
composent au delà de l'objectif de mieux
se connaître l'enjeu c'est également
d'utiliser tout ce contenu pour mieux
promouvoir l'éco stand et paris saclay
notamment dans les actions que nous
allions à l'international leurs deux
participations à des salons
professionnels l'objectif principal
c'est vraiment de convaincre les
entreprises de venir rejoindre
écosystèmes
[Musique]
dans cette cartographie à paris saclay
nous avons répertorié l'ensemble des
entreprises sur paris saclay qui
travaille avec des chercheurs qui
produisent des retrads de recherche en y
a nous avons trouvé 110 start up créée
depuis 2010 sur ces thématiques et enfin
80 à 90 entreprises pme tei qu'en groupe
qui travaille fortement avec paris
saclay sur ces thématiques ja nous avons
aussi recensé 42 laboratoire de
recherche d'un très haut niveau
académique qui travaillent sur l'ia sur
plusieurs thématiques de l'ia qui sont
fédérés sur deux blocs qui sont à y
parisse plutôt pour ip pays l'institut
polytechnique de paris et ensuite data
ya plutôt pour l'université paris saclay
et inria et enfin et pour conclure en
termes d'indicateurs paris saclay abrite
17 % des laboratoires nationaux qui
travaillent sur l'intelligence
artificielle mais 41% des stars
chercheurs entrepreneurs confondues qui
font de l'intelligence artificielle et
un autre chiffre très important c'est
que dans l'appel à projets de la nr sur
les chairs en intelligence artificielle
paris saclay a remporté 16 des 40
projets ce qui correspond à 40 % des
projets actuels entre industrie et
recherche fondamentale sur l'île
intelligence artificielle donc pas
forcément beaucoup de laboratoires
beaucoup de laboratoires haut niveau
nationale travaille sur l'ia mais une
qualité importante de la recherche qui
transparaît à travers ses chiffres enfin
la sat met en place d'autres actions
d'attractivité du territoire typiquement
avec le showroom technologique qui se
visitent
[Musique]
une porte d'entrée dans notre beau
territoire d'excellence académique et
industriel le showroom technologique
mutualisé de la sat paris-saclay du
playground est un outil marketing par
excellence qui présente la structuration
du territoire la complexité des échanges
entre ces acteurs les filières présentes
sur le territoire et hop bien sûr les
technologies de pointe à travers notre
exposition des start-up l'avantagé la
singularité de notre showroom c'est
d'être vraiment en showroom transverses
qui est une porte d'entrée sur le
territoire qui permet vraiment a
rapidement comprendre les enjeux du
territoire paris saclay qui à travers
son exposition permet d'entrevoir
quelles sont les possibilités qui
s'offrent à des acteurs nationaux et
internationaux
venant en visite sur le territoire et
travaillant dans les laboratoires de
recherche dans les lieux d'excellence
académique et industriel dans les
entreprises quel est l'intérêt d'être
présent sur ce territoire nous pouvons
le voir à travers l'exposition de notre
chaudron technologique mutualisés
[Musique]
oh